what I want to do in this video is to
create a simple spreadsheet to help us
understand why if R is greater than G
why that might lead to more and more of
national income going to the owners of
capital as opposed to labor so let's
just say R is 3% we can change that
assumption later so that's the return on
capital that we're assuming we're
assuming it's just going to be fixed at
that constant rate and let's say that
economic growth is 2% so we're assuming
a scenario where R is greater than G now
this column let me write the year so is
year 1 year 2 and then we go let's see
maybe we can go up to year let's go to
year 15 just for good measure
now we could think about what are our
national capital is or going to say
total capital so the capital in our
economy now we'd also want to think
about the national income so because
view this is the output of the economy
national income and now we could think
about the split of the income between
capital and labor so income to capital
and income to labor and now let's just
think about percentage of total so
capital as percent of total so let's
come up with some assumptions right over
here so let's say that our aggregate
capital and I'm just going to throw out
a random number here let's say it's
4,000 and if we're talking about
millions of dollars and this would be 4
trillion dollars but I'm being currency
agnostic right over here so let's just
say it's 4,000 it could be this could if
we're this it was in millions we would
this would be 4 trillion but let's just
say 4,000 for now and let's say our
national income is 1000 and we've seen
charts already that at least for the
u.s. the capital national capital as a
percentage of national income has been
about four or five hundred percent it's
kind of oscillated in that range so it's
been about four or five times national
income so these are this kind of a not
unreasonable ratio and now what's the
income to the owners of capital well
we're saying that the return on capital
is 3% so this is going to be equal to
this 3%
to press f4 to put those dollar signs
and we'll see why that's valuable make
sure that we stay referenced to that
cell as we drag this down later on it's
going to be that x times the amount of
capital that we have in the economy so
it's going to be 120 and notice I had
the dollar signs on the b1 because I
always want to refer to this but I
didn't put the dollar signs on the b5
because as I drag this down I always
want this cell say look when I drag it
down here I want to refer to that same
3% so that's why I kind of anchored it
there with the dollar signs but I want
it to be times the capital in that row
so we'll see how that happens in a
second now what's the income to labor
well it's going to be what's left over
national income minus the income to
capital and then capital is a percentage
of total the income to capital as a
percentage of total income well that's
just going to be equal to I can select
income to capital d5 / / national income
and so it's 12% and we're also going to
assume that every year that income to
capital all gets reinvested as capital
so it doesn't get consumed in some way
so the near to the capital that we start
off with is going to be the capital from
last year plus the new income to capital
that capital that's that that income to
capital is going to get reinvested as
capital it's just going to be my
assumption there and national income
well we know it's growth it's going to
be the previous year's national income
plus I guess we could say x times 1 plus
this number plus our economic growth so
there and I'll press f4 because I keep I
want to stay referencing that and so
notice we grew by 2% and then these two
over here actually all three of these
over here we can just drag down and now
hopefully you see the value of what I
did when I put the dollar signs here
because now when I drew when I dragged
it down this is still referring to B 1
because I have the dollar signs they're
just hanging the 3% times B 6
so b6 is this so it's looking at the
right at that the B column but in its
row now that's what's one of the really
useful things about spreadsheets and
actually this column let me make this
let me make this a percentage just so it
becomes a little bit cleaner okay there
you go
and then we can just keep on going so
let's just keep on going down and what
do we get it actually let me get rid of
some of the decimal places here it's
making it a little bit messy so let me
so there you go that actually makes it a
little bit cleaner and so what do we
have going on over here well we see that
when R is a fixed rate of return on
capital that is greater than growth we
see that capital the income going to
capital as a percentage of the total
national income is increasing now this
could be used as a proxy for inequality
because as we've said before capital
does tend to be concentrated amongst the
the upper percentile decile quartile
would however you want you want to
define it but once again this is just a
proxy and the other thing you have to
keep in mind is inequality is a natural
byproduct of a capitalistic market
economy and even though more and more of
the income is going to the owners of
capital the labor the income where labor
is also increasing now that by itself
doesn't necessarily say it's a good
thing for example if the population were
increasing faster than this then the
income to labor divided by the
population which would be kind of the
per capita income to labor or kind of a
proxy for how much the individual person
working is making then if that even if
this is going up with the population is
growing faster than that that might not
be a good thing because that means per
capita income might not be where it
needs to be but if we assume the
population is stable or it's not growing
as fast as this even though we see
inequality or at least this measure of
inequality going up more and more of the
income is going to capital these people
still still might be better off in this
reality but just to kind of test the
sensitivity of this model that we've
created we can actually try different
things so if the return on capital is
much larger so it's 5%
we see that the disparity the disparity
becomes much much more significant and
let's say if it was 10% now you see a
situation that could get not so pleasant
because in this situation and this is a
fairly extreme situation we have right
over here now sudden the income to labor
and apps was not even on per capita
terms is actually decreasing so it
really does matter a lot where these two
numbers are but of course if economic
growth was also pretty robust now all of
a sudden was this is still decreasing
but if economic growth was 9 percent now
of a sudden this could be a pretty good
scenario for everyone involved you do
have at least this is kind of a proxy
for increased income to capital which
could be a proxy for inequality but
maybe the economy is growing fast enough
that everyone is benefiting so I
encourage you to either build a model
like this or I'll give you the link to
this model as well and play with these
numbers and just try to get a better
understanding for if we assumed R and G
were constant and we made some
assumptions about starting capital and
national income how that ends up
breaking down as we go further and
further into the future